we've got beautiful skies out there this
morning some clouds around the sun is on
its way up and some neighborhoods have
already been a little bit windy some
pretty good breezes boulder city over
the south valley and up in our local
mountains we've had gusts over 40 miles
an hour overnight so we've got a lot of
40s taking over a few 50s left but some
cool low 40s on the west side snow is
making its way through the intermountain
west all the way up through the bitter
roots of idaho into the northern rockies
so it's chilly in those areas reno
getting a little snow this morning and
there's a lot of rain and snow moving
into california and you saw the wet live
picture from lax in los angeles let's
get over to the east side of the country
where we've got a mix now of
temperatures cold after that big cold
front moving through over the weekend in
the tornado tornado ravaged areas of the
mid-south but look at this there is
another increase of warming of
temperatures and we talked about this as
the unprecedented warm temps hundreds
and hundreds of record highs in the
month of december because it's been so
unusually warm now more warm air is
being pumped into the south all the way
up into little rock temperatures are
rising into the 50s and there is rain on
the way unfortunately rain for the areas
where the devastation has been since
those deadly tornadoes so take a look at
still some of the pictures that are
coming in more than 75 people now have
been
have been killed in these tornadoes and
over 100 people still unaccounted for
still missing so they are looking
furiously fast and furiously with search
dogs as much as they can as fast as they
can for people who may still be trapped
in some of these homes over a thousand
homes just absolutely destroyed some of
them obliterated in these areas of
kentucky and
they'll be looking for days as long as
they can and repair could take months
they're saying it's going to take a long
time so our hearts go out for the people
back there suffering and so close to the
holidays completely different type of
holidays for the folks back there rain
snow snow is piling up in the sierras
unfortunately the sierras will be the
road block for intercepting a lot of
this moisture but we're getting some
snow now in our local mountains winter
storm warnings have been in effect since
four o'clock this morning for central
nevada as well as our own local
mountains snow levels are expected down
to about 5 000 feet if you don't need to
be in the mountains today please don't
travel up there it is going to get
snowier and snowier as the day goes on
wind advisories start in just a little
bit a few minutes from now at 7 a.m
until
seven o'clock tonight we're looking at
45 50 mile an hour winds they've already
been 40 plus in the mountains so snow in
higher elevations rain below 5000 feet
and we're looking for developing showers
at least by noon if not sooner all
through the afternoon with strong gusty
winds today so give yourself time to get
to where you're going and we'll look for
the rain until about nine o'clock
tonight then this system will move out
and chillier temperatures again into the
low 50s with mornings near freezing all
the way up until the weekend